je veux que on est dès la sixième de
cette année qu'on commence à avoir des
élèves qui plantent des arbres et qu'on
est cette génération où chaque collégien
aura planté son arbre on n'arrivera pas
je pense à le faire pour l'intégralité
des sixièmes mais si on a chaque
génération qui tourne son arme ils vont
nous aider à aller à notre milliard de
reboisement c'est hyper important pour
la Sainte Catherine ensuite je continue
donc pas ça qu'un versera la courbe des
émissions que vous avez fait ça mais
rien pas plus que ce que vous m'avez dit
tout à l'heure surprendre moins d'avion
les avions un peu plus que c'est tous
ces gestes ce que je vous ai dit sur
l'avion plus j'évite un vol inutile plus
en effet je reboise pardon il y a des
choses qui ont plus d'impact que
d'autres questions
de la République mais là c'est les
sentiments j'ai le droit et elle a
autant de gueule que celle de celle des
copains je suis scientifique mais en
l'occurrence mais non mais moi aussi
c'est les scientifiques il faut reboiser
oui